[Applaudissements]
vrai ou faux secrets de stars parce que
votre album s'appelle le secret je vous
propose des secrets de stars ou bien
s'ils sont vrais ou faux
gérard depardieu a été garde du corps de
prostituées vrai ou faux et voilà ce que
vous pensez que j'ai un peu de culture
en fait c'est non mais c'est pas moi je
le savais pas mais c'est vrai mais non
c'est vrai il est des jours que je
vivrai quand il était jeune
exactement il a été garde du corps de
prostituées qui descendait à paris qui
descendait de paris au centre de la
france
en fait on a suivi tout le périple et ça
donne un reportage formidable regarder
nelson monfort n'irai pas chez le
coiffeur mais chez un toiletteur on
allume à votre avis mais je pense je
pense que là ya exagération il ya
exagération mersali j'adore parce que
elle est très précise à l'ats il y a
exagéré quand il était jeune barack
obama fait une crête sur la tête des
chaînes en or il se faisait appeler
barracuda
[Rires]
françois fillon fut temporairement
expulsé de son collège pour avoir jeté
une ampoule lacrymogènes en cours ah
ouais c'est vrai c'était inscrit le gars
grosse keira tous des élèves ont dû être
évacués d'urgence
c'est bien aussi non mais c'est vrai
donc voilà donc il a lu je peux ouvrir
méfiez-vous ne faut pas sans moyens et
que lui en prenant pour lacrymogènes
dans la gueule ça va calmer tout le
monde
le vrai nom de chuck norris et carlos
c'est vrai ou faux vous dites que c'est
pau non c'est bon c'est vrai il ya un an
qu il savait où 1 au nom donc jeter ou
plichon de nos actes et charcutiers oui
oui oui c'est moi vous appelez lara
fabian
oui c'est vrai ça vous le saviez ça oui
quand très bien même si j'ai quand il
n'y a pas d'émission le père fouras
organise des clashs de rap dans son
phare ça peut être possible
non c'est faux françois hollande et
sébastien cauet ne sont en fait qu'une
seule et même personne
[Rires]
elle a décroché une petite dernière
johnny hallyday a été petit rat de
l'opéra vrai ou faux nom avec cette tête
là ah non c'est vrai je vous permets
qu'on apprend des choses dans cette
émission tosi petit rat de l'opéra
et ouais à l'âge de 6 ans il prenait 7
heures de cours de danse par jour un
match pour rien et en tutu et vas-y que
je t'aime de johnny lara fabian le
secret l'album est déjà sorti et puis
carafe à lyon
c'est en concert le 16 et 10